montrer que l'industrie compatible avec
le développement durable c'est
l'objectif de cette visite de yannick
jadot la tête de liste d'europe écologie
les verts pour le scrutin européen est
ici avec quatre autres candidats
notamment la bourguignonne catherine
hervieu et la franc comtoise anna
maillard ici 35 personnes travaillent
tant d'insertion à la collecte et au
recyclage des déchets électroniques
notamment des frigos et à des écrans de
télévision je vous propose d'écouter
yannick jadot député européen sortant
donc c'est ça qu'on veut porter dans la
campagne des entreprises qui intègrent
l'environnement qui intègre le
l'émancipation de chacune et de chacun
dans l'entreprise qui intègre insertion
sociale et qui réussissent ça marche
l'écologie ça marche crédité de 8 à 9 %
dans les sondages europe ecologie les
verts veut créer la surprise au scrutin
européen quatrième force politique dans
les intentions de vote le parti
écologiste talonne les républicains est
au même niveau que la france insoumise
arrivé en tête des forces de gauche
serait pour europe ecologie les verts
une belle performance